joining me now n Gingrich former speaker
of the house and Fox News contributor
new groceries gas pric is increasing
again um there are the two things
everyone seems to go back to the two
things that everyone needs and here we
are bomic is working
n well this may be one of the great
strategic mistakes for re-election that
anybody's made in modern times
fidonomics is going to become an
absurdity the average everyday American
knows that the price of gasoline is
going up and by the way every indication
is that the Biden Administration
policies are going to make gasoline even
more expensive so gasoline is a major
factor in the Consumer Price Index and
as it keeps going up you're going to see
the inflation go up at the same time
everybody who goes grocery shopping uh
and clist and I did this over the
weekend you're startled by some of the
prices and you know that Joe Biden he
you know he live has a great chef at the
White House he gets to fly Air Force One
he gets to go to Wilmington and be
surrounded by people I don't think they
have a clue how bad inflation is high
prices are for the average American and
Biden omics may be one of the reasons
that one of the most important deep stap
colonists uh David ignacius wrote a
column this morning saying Biden should
drop out I think this begin to sink in
to Democrats that Biden getting
reelected is going to be very very hard
no I I think what's been amazing about
this from the very beginning in this
Administration is that they think that
every problem is just a PR problem we
have to communicate it better people we
people don't see it the way we're saying
it but in reality it's a substance
problem I mean they're shutting off oil
supplies exploration cordoning off land
that can't be drilled and so now well
well turns out our utilities are going
to be Skyhigh this winter new report
just came out about that and all the
other things we're seeing so it's not a
PR or messaging problem this is a policy
problem and it has been across the
board look if if you are a Hardline left
Winger uh you believe in a world that's
a fantasy now if you really believe in
that world you can't face any facts
because the facts would destroy your
belief system so you make things up
uh and you get used to lying to each
other and that makes you out of touch
with reality I thought the other day
when the Secretary of Energy couldn't
actually take the drive in the electric
vehicle cuz for example I think there
only 37 uh charging stations in all of
West Virginia uh and here she has out in
a PR stunt and it turns out they they
staffed it so stupidly they didn't
realize she couldn't possibly do what
they were promising this kind of stuff
goes on every day in this Administration
new really quickly on that New Mexico
concealed uh carry and open carry ban um
that was in put into place by the New
Mexico Governor uh because of a gun
violence quote emergency was slapped
down temporarily your quick reaction to
that the governor is crazy it's another
example of the rule of power uh
replacing the rule of law there is no
constitutional provision that allows her
to do that and by the way she has to be
personally unilaterally suspending New
Mexico law to do it it is an example of
the total power that the left believes
they have to tell us what to do yeah and
uh Biden got slapped down with a student
loan forgiven I mean they left and right
they're getting hit by all these
unconstitutional Moves new great to see
you tonight as always hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else